bonjour bienvenue au palais ducal de
nevers pour le premier débat des
élections municipales sur france 3
bourgogne tous nos invités nous
attendent sur le plateau on va dire
joindre
tous les samedis jusqu'au premier tour
des élections municipales nous serons
donc en direct dans une grande ville de
bourgogne pour organiser et animer le
débat et nous sommes donc aujourd'hui à
nevers dans cette très belle salle des
mariages du palais ducal en partenariat
avec le journal du centre nos verts qui
est l'historique de la gauche dirigée
aujourd'hui par florent sainte fare
garnot socialiste candidat à sa propre
succession bonjour dans ce débat
guillaume maillard pour lui dit bonjour
bonjour michel nestor candidat du prg
merci bonjour bonjour à vous excusez moi
je trouve mais on ne sait pas bien
philippe cordier candidat du mcg bonjour
et merci bonjour merci d merci d'être
avec nous denis thuriau candidat sans
étiquette pour cette élection
bonjour bonjour et christophe gaillard
candidat du front national bien le
bonjour chez vous vous pouvez réagir à
ce débat sur notre site internet sur
twitter avec le hashtag envel bourgogne
et 3 bourgogne un certain nombre de vos
réactions seront affichés à l'antenne
rajoutons que est candidate aussi pour
cette élection municipale de nevers
geneviève lemoine pour la liste lutte
ouvrière on va donc faire de la
politique avec les enjeux nationaux avec
les spécificités locales
on abordera avec stéphane vergeade mon
confrère du journal du centre un certain
nombre de points précis de la vie de
nevers mais on va commencer d'abord par
la ville elle-même
dites nous comment vous la voyez ce que
vous aimez et puis ce qui ne vous plaît
pas en commençant pour le coup par le
maire florent sainte fare garnot d'abord
je vois que nos verts est une ville qui
a une richesse culturelle exceptionnelle
et associatives ça fait partie de ces
richesses qui sont hors du commun pour
une ville de notre taille ensuite c'est
une ville qui a un cadre de vie et une
qualité de vie vraiment exceptionnel
tous les gens qui découvrent la ville me
disent que voilà il son charme et qu'ils
ont plaisir à la découvrir et vraiment
de manière générale les échos sont
extrêmement bon tout est à 10 minutes à
nevers on à la loire le patrimoine des
services des écoles de grande qualité
et puis je le dis
parce que je le crois sincèrement la
ville a pris un virage dynamique depuis
trois ans avec le projet du rugby le
musée de la faïence qui rayonne
fortement avec le cas des mariniers avec
le multiplexe autant de choses qui
avancent mais il faut aussi lorsqu'on
est maire être lucide et et regarder les
problèmes tels qu'ils sont et
incontestablement la mondialisation et
la désindustrialisation touche notre
territoire et de ce point de vue là il
ya une question qui est celle de
l'emploi qui est au coeur du combat que
je mène avec mon équipe et qui le serait
non mandat prochain gilles cordier votre
vision ma vision vient vous allez bien
de comprendre n'est pas la même que
notre jeu ça fait regardez moi ce que je
constate c'est quand je me promène dans
le vert une ville qui est délabré je
dirais une mairie qui est entouré tôt
une porte de paris qui a défilé on paye
des impôts parce que cela falloir bien
d'en débattre des impôts locaux qui sont
quand même extrêmement cher par rapport
aux prestations proposées dans les gérer
projets réalisés du maire le square de
la résistance avec un côté une surface
commerciale qui ne fait pas en fait les
qik ne fait pas ce qu'elle devrait faire
je pense que celle là c'est un échec
mais également avec des surfaces de
location qui sont vides au niveau des
galeries marchandes
donc je vous comprenez bien que je n'ai
pas le même constat que le maire ce qui
est un peu normal et je suis très étonné
si vous voulez du slogan de sa liste où
ce slogan et et nevers en marche je
crois je crois qu'on avance surtout dans
le mur et quelques points d'avancé un
peu à reculons coupe ni thuriau vous
êtes candidat vous sans étiquette c'est
comme ça que vous vous déclarez oui vous
m'avez d'ailleurs placé un endroit parmi
les autres candidats de gauche moi je ne
suis pas spécialement candidat de gauche
je suis un candidat d'ouverture
une liste sans étiquette que vous l'avez
rappelé indépendant de tout parti échoué
très confirmé ce constat parce que
malheureusement et ça aurait été
pourtant mon souhait je suis nos verts
soient d'origine j'ai fait choix d'y
revenir dix villes d'y travailler et je
regrette aujourd'hui que justement nos
verres n'avance pas du tout et nevers
patine
je vais pas revenir sur le déclin des
populations déclin économique qui a été
rappelé il y a par contre des atouts et
ses atouts il suffit pas dire on a un
cadre de vie on s'y trouve bien ça ne
suffit pas il faut d'emploi comme
beaucoup de gens le demandent et il n'y
en a plus il n'y en a pas il y a eu d'un
manque d'anticipation à manque
d'ambition de notre ville est
aujourd'hui il faut tout mettre en
oeuvre pour faire revenir un nouveau dit
une nouvelle dynamique et ça c'est
indispensable
on ne peut pas se contenter de dire ça
avance ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
compris christophe gaillard il ya
effectivement moi je partage un certain
nombre de constats concernant
l'attractivité de la ville concernant
son rayonnement bien sûr mais je
voudrais d'abord dire que mon engagement
pour ce qui concerne ma candidature à la
mairie de nevers mon engagement se situe
nettement au delà des querelles
partisanes habituel de l'ump du ps et c
est que cet engagement il se situe aussi
au delà de la seule ville de nevers
c'est un engagement qui se place qui se
situe aussi dans l'agglomération de
nevers que largement pour le département
parce que nevers c'est vrai regorge de
richesses nevers est une ville qui a
beaucoup de richesses la nièvre
également qu'ils sont peut-être pas
souvent pacy ne pas assez souvent pardon
exploiter
mais ce moteur qui est nevers le moteur
du département ce moteur aujourd'hui il
est quand même un peu gris
et tout le monde partage ce constat
l'insee vient de sortir des chiffres la
vente hier on voit bien que
effectivement il ya un déclin
démographique il ya deux des pertes
d'emplois qui sont quand même assez
importante plus importante que dans les
départements et les régions voisines à
chiffres constants on perd beaucoup
d'emplois sur dix ans et 5000 emplois
5000 habitants environ donc je voudrais
moi simplement rappelé qu' il ya un
bilan qui est que je critique beaucoup
le bilan du maire sortant
mais je voudrais aussi rappeler que j'ai
moi même participé à beaucoup d'action
économique associative dans ce
département et plus particulièrement à
nouvelles et notamment en étant à la
tête d'une structure d'insertion d'une
structure associative 200 personnes qui
généraient un chiffre d'affaires très
important que j'ai relevé et donc je
suis fier d'avoir fait de belles et de
bonnes choses à nevers concernant cette
structure cette association et j ai même
une entreprise depuis 19 ans donc je
pense qu'il ya des choses à faire on
peut faire des choses mais autrement et
avec ses vrais plus d'ambition je
restaure oui écoutez le constat immédiat
c'est la gestion calamiteuse de la ville
et cette gestion elle s'explique pour
une simple raison le parti socialiste
vers soi n'est plus de gauche depuis
bien longtemps
comme vous le savez j'ai été conseiller
municipal dans cette majorité de 2001 à
une collaboration absolument ainsi à une
intéressante et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai refusé de poursuivre et
dès 2008 j'étais candidat à cette même
municipal et nous avons recueilli près
de 8% des suffrages
j'ai d'ailleurs au passage rejeté de
confortables indemnités
ce qui n'est pas le cas de toutes les
forces affiché de gauche aujourd'hui est
donc 2014
je suis un nouveau candidat d'ailleurs
vous remarquerez que je suis seule tête
de liste encore présents nous avons donc
de la suite dans les idées
et quand je regarde nouvelle je suis
stupéfait tu peux fait de voir une ville
à deux heures de paris ne soit par la
route que ce soit par le train la
proximité de la loire un patrimoine
architectural culturel historique qui ne
demande qu'à être développé qui ne
demande qu'à être utilisé en premier
lieu je pense au développement et au
soutien de nos tpe pme 90% des emplois
sont créés par les tpe
c'est ça la chance de nevers il faut
prendre soin de nos entreprises la
première action que nous mettrons en
oeuvre c'est de créer une cellule
d'action tpe pme pour faire le lien
entre les institutionnels et les
entreprises et il lui faudra même
pourquoi pas soutenir ses entreprises
financièrement aux consultants en
cautionnant les prêts de trésorerie les
prêts d'investissement
vous anticipez sûr je sais pas mais
c'est pas je sais bien c'est vrai que
c'est le coeur du sujet monsieur sont
pas aussi la fiscalité on vas y on va y
venir juste après sur ce que vous
proposez je pense qu'avant les
propositions compte tenu de la
disposition de la table français
regardent d'eau et à écouter les tirs
venant d'un peu partout
un petit mot avant qu'on passe au
programme quand même ville délabrée
villes en difficulté
écoutez je crois qu'on ne vivons pas le
même rapport à la ville moi j'ai un
rapport à la fois lucide mais
d'affection et d'attachement lucide ça
veut dire que je voie ce qui a été
construit ce qui a gagné depuis ces
dernières années et c'est je crois
reconnu par les notaires soit il est
normal bien sûr lorsqu'on monte à
l'assaut d'une élection que l'on
noircissent le tableau mais à ce point
là je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui
relève du dénigrement et je ne veux pas
y participer you may à la ville pour
vous aujourd'hui au titre de au titre
dudit effectivement il faut être clair
c'est un véritable cas où monsieur le
maire je suis arrivé dans la nièvre en
2008 vous étiez vous étiez partis de la
majorité en place
je vois nos verres se vident et je pense
que le plus grand chaos c'est le
baromètre c'est des habitants je veux
rappeler quand même en hiver soit une
versoix ce que nous sommes face à un
exode vertigineux de la population quand
je dis vertigineuse et pèse mes mots
en 2008 nous étions prêtres 44 mille
habitants
44 mille habitants en 2014 les chiffres
de la préfecture c'est moins de trente
six mille habitants
nous avons perdu huit mille habitants en
six ans c'est l'équivalent d'une ville
comme châtillon en bazois tous les ans
qui quittent 9h qui va ou qui va ou qui
va dans la périphérie de nevers parce
que on peut parler fiscalité
la fiscalité est lourde nevers a des
atouts je reprends un petit peu les
les propos de mes confrères ne verra des
grands châteaux par contre nous vers une
fiscalité qui est dévorante nevers
n'attire plus les gens les nouveaux
arrivants les noeuds vers soi quitte 9
heures c'est un vrai problème
alors on peut passer à ce que vous
proposez en plaisantant préparant cette
émission disait on pourrait pasticher en
disant moi mr comme candidat des émois
président vous mr vous mr que ferez vous
une chaîne est hors jeu vous aviez
commencé je vous propose de continuer
vous avez parlé de tp tout le monde a
parlé de fiscalité aussi on sait par les
enquêtes d'opinion qu'aujourd'hui la
fiscalité locale c'est peut-être un des
sujets qui qui arrivent le plus souvent
dans ce débat là alors aux affaires vous
mr aujourd'hui la ville de nevers a les
moyens de baisser sa fiscalité de 20 %
sur six ans c'est ce que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre il faut en finir avec
cette logique qui consiste à monopoliser
les financements publics pour financer
des investissements structurants il faut
développer des délégations de service
public il faut développer des
partenariats public privé parce que
cette logique la politique menée depuis
40 ans a creusé un écart énorme sur les
investissements structurants entre les
villes moyennes et nevers
de plus des actions pourront être très
vite programmée grâce à des mesures
d'économie de redéploiements de postes
mais également derrière des
réorientations de moyens de vente de
biens immobiliers appartenant à la ville
ainsi dès cette année dès cette année
nous pouvons réduire la pression fiscale
exercée sur les neuf et reçoit le budget
de fonctionnement pour ne reprendre que
le budget de fonctionnement est
excédentaire de près de 7 millions
d'euros
ces 7 millions ne servent qu'à de
l'investissement en retranchant
simplement 4 millions d'euros divisé par
20 mille foyers nous proposons dès cette
année le rendre 200 euros à chaque fois
yen à versoix et ça c'est une politique
et ça c'est une politique de gauche
c'est concret christophe gaillard vous
avez beaucoup appuyé sur la fiscalité en
proposant de la réduire
très fortement sur le très fortement oui
parce que c'est possible
florent sainte fare garnot avec son
équipe l'a démontré sauf que les
économies qu'ils ont réalisés ou qu'ils
disent avoir réalisé son des économies
sur le fonctionnement
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est simplement
sans faire de surenchère c'est redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux nevers soit
effectivement c'est à dire réduire la
pression fiscale de 30 % concernant les
taxes locales des impôts locaux de 30%
sur la mandature
ce qui fait aller 5 % par an environ et
ce qui donne à peu près un million un
million deux d'économies par an sur deux
baisses de recettes par an pour
l'amérique nouvelle mouvement est ce que
ça limite pas la capacité de la ville à
faire des choix écoutez je pense que le
parti socialiste de florent sainte fare
garnot l'a fait et ils ont démontré que
par ailleurs ils ont pu faire un certain
nombre de projets conduire des
initiatives donc moi je ne suis pas plus
bêtes que florent sainte fare garnot je
pense que j'ai su démontrer dans mon
bilan est dans mon parcours que j'ai
relevé des structures et notamment qui
étaient mises en difficulté par le parti
socialiste à nevers donc ce qu'a fait le
parti socialiste le front national
pourra le faire
guillaume maillard je vous ai vu quand
je me suis permis de faire une remarque
en disant est ce que ça limite pas la
possibilité de la ville oui j'avais
aussi le vélo je peux oui je pense qu'il
faut être raisonnable la fiscalité forte
à nevers on le sait c'est un thème qui
anime beaucoup de débat politique depuis
plusieurs années je rappelle quand même
que nevers c'est la ville qui a la
fiscalité la plus forte de bourgogne
c'est important ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit ce sont les chiffres
la compta fiscalité est lourde mais il
faut rétablir un nouvel équilibre
porteurs de richesses
je pense qu'il faut créer une dynamique
il faut faire attention à ne pas être
trop ambitieux une marge de manoeuvre
sont pas évidentes
monsieur merde c'est très bien
il faut prendre le pari de faire un
frein sur la fiscalité je pense que c
est plutôt le message à prendre de mon
côté c'est un frein sur la fiscalité
redonner confiance rétablir un climat de
confiance
redonner une dynamique à nevers ça c'est
important après les ambitions de des
autres candidats de réduire fortement la
fiscalité
immédiatement je pense que c'est un
petit peu imprudent les cornées écoutez
moi j'entends des chiffres des chiffres
qui me paraissent quelquefois un peu
fort mais nous avons nous étudiions fort
vous voulez dire les 30% par exemple %
par exemple et nous avons donc de
rechercher fait des études et je
voudrais monter un petit peu à la
télévision
ceci vous voyez tout tout ce qui est en
rouge chênevert taxe d'habitation taxe
du foncier et taxe foncier non bâti
estac des propriétés bâties
donc comme vous le voyez nous sommes
quand même au haut niveau ça c crosser
soit les autres bars puisque ce jeune
garçon des deux villes deux strates
comparable à la nôtre
donc je vais vous l'aviez pas dit c'est
plus roanne bonne dolma combres du songe
chibout rejoue moulin troyes châteauroux
auxerre chalon bleu vert pour ce qui
concerne la taxe à visalia vous
anticipez sont au débat sur donc voilà
je suis l'impression que tout le monde
anticipe quoi si vous voulez que le plan
en fait de votre émission commence à
battre un petit peu de l'ale c'est pour
ça que je voudrais moi aussi mimi ses
danseurs comment j'aime pas forcément
l'offre g1 effectivement un tempérament
scientifique et j'aime bien les choses
soient respectés dont apparemment
interdire la liberté bon bah on a oui
oui on pourra éventuellement discuter
parvenir aussi pour l'instant la
fiscalité qui doit traite quelque chose
c'est là justement très bien encadrés je
pense à et la liberté dans la fiscalité
ne faut pas que ça soit n'importe quoi
nous nous avons chiffré enfin exactement
les économique nous pouvons faire au
sein de la berri et je peux vous
affirmer que nous pouvons baisser pas
2014 puisque nous avons voté le budget
et
pas si mécha bon je vais exprimer en
conseil municipal donc je veux pas y
revenir
déni de démocratie parce qu en fait
l'équipe actuelle pense en fait qu'elle
sera toujours aux commandes à la
prochaine dans la prochaine mandature
par contre ce que nous avons nous
chiffres et c'est qu'en 2015
nous pouvons faire 2 4 millions
d'économies est donc décédé 2015 dès
j'en tombe bien la pression fiscale de
10% alors j'irai pas sur des chiffres
plus importants que sont que 10%
ça me paraît largement suffisant et que
effectivement je la première demande des
noeuds vers soi moi je suis né vers soi
depuis extrêmement longtemps j'ai fait
mes études à nevers petit 10 et 17
journal jeune femme issue d'une famille
de commerçants en huit ans le vert donc
je vois bien comment la ville a évolué
et ceux ci voulaient est actuellement
sept villes hôtes je vais me répéter
mais cette ville est un est en déclin
donc en fait ce déclin il est due
également à l'imposition trop importante
monique thuriau ou écoutez je crois
qu'il faut arrêter dire que nova est
frappé par la mondialisation tout être
sérieux nevers un potentiel on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
simplement il faut être déterminé tout
une tout une question de volonté dans la
vie et de bon sens à partir du moment où
on fait choix de vouloir mettre en
valeur les atouts que nous avons nous
sommes connus sur la scène
internationale par la faïence par
l'espace et la chason bernadette par
l'entreprise look cycle notamment et est
également time et par d'autres par bien
d'autres avantages nous sommes une
région centrale en france et bien le
constat est le suivant nous avons la
même population et je le dis aux verts
soit 0,2 vers soi qu'en 1954 qu'en 1954
à peu près trente six mille habitants
c'est tout à fait vérifiable
alors il faut sortir de cette spirale et
à partir de ce moment là il faut faire
des choix
nous on verra bien nous sommes engagés
ne faisons pas des promesses nous avons
posé des engagements depuis un mois sur
nos réseaux sociaux et nous le décliner
dans notre programme
le premier c'est une baisse de la
fiscalité résonner une baisse de la
fiscalité d'un point sur trois ans
chaque année et ce qui fait
effectivement une réduction de rentrer
de l'ordre d'un million d'euros qui
seraient compensés par des économies
sur le fonctionnement de la ville par
une meilleure mutualisation au niveau de
l'agglomération je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler aux électeurs
l'enjeu est aussi de ces élections c'est
l'agglomération et en l'occurrence
l'agglomération de nevers c'est la
première fois que les gens votaient au
suffrage universel pour les conseillers
communautaires et aujourd'hui de faire
de notre ville une véritable
agglomération qui fonctionne à la
confiance avec soixante dix mille
habitants
c'est important ça n'existe pas parce
que j'ai rencontré de nombreux élus qui
font partie de l'agglomération et qui
n'arrive pas à travailler en confiance
avec les élus actuels
il va falloir que les choses changent
elles vont changer naturellement ne
verra plus la majorité et il va falloir
travailler intelligemment et de
confiance avec les autres et l'on sait
que l'agglomération c'est un sujet chaud
sur nevers florent sainte fare garnot a
alors pu récemment dit mais vous avez
vous vous avez baissé 9 s'irriter la
question au fond d'ailleurs derrière ça
c est pourquoi baisser la fiscalité
finalement est-ce que c'est une demande
des citoyens est ce que c'est je vais
provocateur le gadget à la mode de ces
élections municipales c'est la
préoccupation des noeuds vers soi c'est
la préoccupation des habitants c'est le
prochain pardonnez moi mais bon oui
c'est la pause c'est un peu trop
provocateur la secte coeur du débat lors
sur la pression des impétrants à
s'exprimer comment fait avec
l'opposition
enfin il vous sert la soupe rase et rec
de la grinta du tout quand on est
content les chalets c'est vous qui
parlez nous un peu de maîtrise de soi
même vous savez pour exercer des
responsabilités
être maire c'est difficile sinon un
exercice réellement exigeant et donc bon
pendant la période des élections les
promesses fleurissent c'est comme les
fleurs elles ne durent que le temps des
élections sur le projet sur le fond ce
que j'entends faire avec mon équipe et
nevers avant c'est d'abord soutenait les
entreprises par l'innovation
nous l'avons fait avec l'entreprise
selni et sauver 150 emplois avec le chef
d'entreprise en question s'est multiplié
par trois les moyens de nos outils en
soutien à l'économie locale s'est
notamment l' agence de développement
économique
et c'est miser sur la filière bois c'est
un projet qui est extrêmement concret et
nous avons un laboratoire de recherche à
lizac qui travaille sur les bois
composite et qui pourrait vraiment aider
notre filière bois construction aux
entreprises locales à se développer
et en matière de service public le
projet c'est d'abord continuer sur
l'excellence éducative le soutien aux
associations et quelques mesures
forte lancement d'un contrat de groupe
sur des mutuelles de santé qui permettra
à faire des économies pour les neuf et
reçoit une commune l'a fait en france
est un succès extraordinaire c'est 20
euros en moyenne d'économies pour chaque
foyer qui adoptent ce système et sur la
question des impôts moi je ne veux pas
passer à côté du sujet c'est un vrai
sujet nous avons réussi
et croyez moi c'est difficile pendant
les six ans de mandat à empêcher les
dépenses de fonctionnement de la ville
de progresser donc ses 6 millions
d'euros d'économies et nous prenons
l'orientation politique de baisser les
impôts dans ce mandat il faudra pour ça
un peu de croissance
sans quoi on casse la dynamique que nous
sommes en train de lancer pour la ville
la capacité à transformer nos verres un
peu de croissance vous n'êtes pas la
seule à la halle à réclamer où elle
espérait en tout cas vous vouliez dire
quelque chose
oui ma juste aurait un petit peu les
propos monsieur le maire c'est assez
impressionnant la façon dont vous voulez
appliquer de nouvelles dynamiques
moi j'ai quand même un constat ça fait
dix ans que vous êtes là vous êtes
arrivé me semble donc directeur de
cabinet adjoint aux finances puis
désigné maire pas une hummer désigné
maire par monsieur boulot vous êtes pour
moi l'incarnation de 20 ans du système
boulot comment voulez vous insuffler une
nouvelle dynamique votre équipe
nevers avant ce jeu les regarder
attentivement
madame carrillon couvreur à vos côtés je
suis désolé mans renouvellement on a vu
mieux
moi je vois pas comment vous allez
arriver à réimplanter des entreprises à
nevers
arrivé à redonner cette dynamique je
pense qu'un maire aujourd'hui de tête un
maire qui doit se mouiller tous les
jours travailler avec ses confrères avec
l'air avec la collectivité avec
l'agglomération pour donner les moyens à
nevers de progresser je suis très
surpris de voir avec quelle ambition
vous fait fleurir des projets si vous
parlez de projets qui fleurissent j'ai
vu que dernièrement les pelleteuses se
remettait en route j'ai vu que
dernièrement les projets fleurissent et
à la caserne pittié les projets
fleurissent et
au musée de la faïence est en fête
qu'avez vous fait pendant dix ans alors
on va parler des entreprises et du
développement parce que vous ouvrez là
dessus mais une pré poncet bref devant
sainte fare garnot là dessus puisque
vous êtes mis en cause et puis on fera
le tour de tout le monde sur le
développement la communication au fond
ce que je suis d'abord je suis maire
depuis trois ans donc voilà il faut
aussi remettre les choses en place et à
leur juste mesure
je crois et sincèrement c'est à voir
depuis trois ans créer une dynamique de
redéveloppement de la ville et projet
sort plus vite on a parlé le rugby le
multiplex le musée le projet de la
piscine qui est prêt qui est très
attendu par les notaires soit et donc la
dynamique est en place et je n'oublie
pas dans ce domaine ce qui a été fait en
direction des entreprises
le soutien d'entreprises saint denis
c'est une vraie innovation c'est concret
ce n'est pas une promesse en l'air et
ses 150 emplois qui ont été sauvegardés
et l'idée c'est de continuer au fond
nous allons travailler pendant trois ans
a posé les bases d'un nouveau cycle
dynamique pour nos verres et maintenant
ce que je propose c'est d'aller plus
loin et c'est pourquoi je suis candidat
aux élections municipales
monique ryo développement économique
vous en avait parlé tout à l'heure vous
l'avez évoqué très cher sachant que
l'entreprise selni a aussi été sauvée
par des parlementaires d'autres
parlementaires et pas par le maire de
nevers spécifiquement alors je pense
qu'il faut rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar l'économie l'économie c'est le
coeur d'une ville pour notre centre
ville qui dépérit qui a un plan de
circulation complètement incohérent
depuis des années et sachant qu'il ya
dans les cartons david de nevers et je
le sais un plan depuis trois ans qu'on
ne veut pas mettre parce qu'on ne veut
pas en faire un enjeu électoral
la difficulté c'est que ça aurait été un
enjeu économique pour beaucoup mais qui
ne sont plus là parce qu'ils ont déposé
le bilan centre ville donc il faut
revenir à une politique cohérente et il
faut redonner de l'intérêt aux
commerçants qui se sentent voire méprisé
parce qu'on a dit qu'on ne s'occupait
pas deux il y à un quart des vitrines
dans le vert qui sont fermés
pratiquement 25% les dents dans les
villes de notre dimension c'est en
moyenne 11%
il ya quand même des questions à se
poser et moi je ne vois pas où on avance
j'aimerais bien et si j'avais un maire
actuel qui me disait on avance et que je
vois des garanties d'avancement je
dirais bon coup on continue c'est pas le
cas et c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre mouvement est né de verre
venir et nous ambitionnons de
s'intéresser à l'économie qui est de la
compétence d'ailleurs de la commune la
communauté d'agglomération mais pas que
et j'estime qu'à minima et ça n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
il devrait y avoir un élu en charge des
liens avec le monde de l'entreprise avec
le monde de l'artisanat avec le monde du
commerce qui souhaitent l écoute qui
anticipe et surtout qui travaillent en
liaison avec les chambres consulaires
avec les boutiques de gestion dont j'ai
découvert hier que la ville connaissait
l'existence depuis un an alors qu'elle
va fêter ses 30 ans il ya des choses à
faire qui ne sont pas faites aujourd'hui
et c'est pour moi un constat d'échec de
ceux qui ont dirigé la ville
parce que quand on réussit en albret a
continué quand on échoue il faut les il
faut laisser la place à un
renouvellement c'est ce que nous
entendons incarner christophe derrière
vous parler d'entreprises depuis depuis
tout à l'heure
oui je parle un domaine que je connais
bien d'un domaine que je connais bien le
monde de l'entreprise
mais le monde plus largement de
l'entrepreneuriat et je suis étonné de
voir que dans les propositions ou en
tout cas dans les dispositions qui sont
prises pour relever nos verres par le
parti socialiste on ne parle jamais
d'économie sociale et solidaire j'ai été
membre d'honneur de la cresse la chambre
régionale de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
g si vous voulez les projets foisonnent
est-ce qu'ils vont permettre une
remarque oui je lui mais je vous
laisserai continuer bien sûr un certain
nombre de vos arguments sont assez
étonnants dans la bouche d'un candidat
du front national city si vous permettez
cette remarque bien entendu moi je suis
étonné de ne pas entendre les arguments
habituels de votre parti parce que parce
qu'il faut casser cette image du front
national d'antan je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui moi j'ai 19 ans 19 ans
passé économique dernier
et puis j'ai relevé on m'a demandé j'ai
fait une mission à l'époque pour le
parti socialiste de relever une
structure qui était en déficit de 220000
euros à l'époque et en quatre ans on a
relevé le défi avec le conseil
d'administration il y a des solutions il
ya des pistes
aujourd'hui je vois que ces pistes là
elles sont flagrantes elles sont données
par l'insee c'est à dire l'insee
aujourd'hui dit bah en fait l'emploi se
dégrade dans le département dans la
région mais plus particulièrement dans
le département
et il ya que le secteur tertiaire non
marchand qui progresse lui c'est à dire
les associations la justice la police et
on peut pas agir par contre le secteur
marchand traditionnel difficile mais je
vois qu'il ya des difficultés pourquoi
parce qu'il ya pas de prospection
florent sainte fare garnot et c'est son
équipe ne font pas le boulot
la preuve vous avez le fonds de
solidarité européen par exemple qui
avaient un programme de 2000 à 2006 il
n'y a pas eu de projet ici florent
sainte fare garnot arrive à l'époque par
contre le deuxième programme 2007-2013
25% de suppression du fonds de
solidarité européen c'est 65 millions
d'euros qui repart jeunes que vous
souhaitez profiter des fonds de
solidarité européen
mais évidemment il ya des dispositifs
bien sûr et c'est pas contradictoire il
ya des dispositifs qui existent mené 3
jeux fait cette remarque d une tenue de
la motte reparti sur le cheese et moi
j'espérais que vous fassiez cette
remarque est ce que vous en doutiez
j'allais vous la soumettre regardez un
peu si vous voulez le parti socialiste
est ici assis à la table et qui nous dit
aujourd'hui on a des projets mais qui ne
se préoccupe pas de l'économie sociale
et solidaire
ça m'étonne quand même beaucoup alors
que c'est ici qu'il faut pointer du
doigt pour développer des projets alors
messieurs les charges qui attend pour
parler des entreprises mais ont bien sûr
joue oui non non j'ai déjà évoqué tout à
l'heure une de nos préoccupations de nos
priorités une cellule d'action tpe/pme
pourquoi parce que quand on rencontre
les chefs d'entreprise et je re je le
répète 90% des emplois sont créés par
des tpe pme on va pas attendre une
entreprise salvatrice qui va nous créer
1000 emplois comme un mercenaire véran
pompes et des subventions
débranchez sa prise trois ans plus tard
et on voit le cac darmatique il ya trois
3 semaines les salariés qui
manifestaient pour déplorer leurs
conditions de travail
donc une cellule d'action tpe pme c'est
quoi ces rencontres et les chefs
d'entreprises qui travaillent de 8h à
20h 21h le soir et qui n'ont pas le
temps de
pouvoir s'intéresser aux procédures
administratives pour pouvoir faire un
recrutement
et puis pour pouvoir aussi bénéficier
des aides à l'embauché et doute les
êtres qu'ils peuvent bénéficier et je
réitère je réitère aujourd'hui le
système bancaire ne fait plus son
travail et le nombre d'entreprises qui
ne vont peut-être même pas arriver au
mois de juin parce qu'ils n'ont plus de
trésorerie et qui pourraient investir
aussi dans lors de leurs moyens de
travailler qui ne peuvent pas le faire
parce que personne ne veut les suivre
c'est notre travail
faut pas attendre une décision si les
radios c'est notre travail et ça rentre
dans nos compétences et puis dernière
chose dernière chose aujourd'hui on est
dans un monde de bisounours quoi il faut
être clair nous devons c'est ma trop
l'ambiance depuis des buts on voir là la
croissance l'europe ça d'ailleurs
c'est une concurrence entre les villes
moyennes une concurrence féroce et
aujourd'hui on ne prospecte pas il faut
faire venir des petites entreprises et
et ça aujourd'hui le travail n'est pas
fait on risque si on se construit avec
des subventions y compris avec des
subventions et les aides mais déjà avec
un service tout à l'heure je vous
parlais pas ses passages au sens de ma
question c'était des êtres des aides
conditionnées à ce que vous dites faut
faire venir les entreprises
on sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya ce cette
bataille donc mais déjà je viens de vous
n'écoutez pas je vienne vous gêne vous
expliquer la véritable problématique il
faut de la simplification administrative
il faut aider les entreprises à accéder
à déjà existants après on verra s'il
faut mettre de l'argent sur la table
pour ça que je vous dis aujourd'hui nous
la fiscalité on peut pas baisser les
impôts maintenant comment est ce sera
déjà ça
c'est le summum de la compétence on se
demande ce qu'ils font dans l'opposition
ils servent la soupe à la majorité c'est
pour ça aussi aujourd'hui que on est sur
ce constat de déclin c'est parce que
quand vous n'avez plus une opposition
qui travaille ses dossiers qui fait une
contre-proposition
eh ben on en est là maya vous lirez
prennent juste sur le développement
économique
les deux la france part donc à juste
vous dire le progrès économique
il faut faire attention de bien
recentrer le débat sur nevers nous
sommes ici dans le cas des élections
municipales de nouvelles
un verre c'est une ville de 36 mille
habitants il ya une agglomération
on a supposé considération pour
reprendre ce que disait denis thuriau
parler de mondialisation c'est se cacher
un petit peu derrière un grand mot pour
reprendre un petit peu des fois pour
monsieur est hors jeu
armatis et 400 emplois selon la zone de
nevers saint-eloi il ya beaucoup de
projets industriels aujourd'hui qui font
appel à du partenariat public privé je
suis moi-même chef d'entreprise j'ai
monté des opérations encore dernièrement
où nous sommes systématiquement dans une
recherche de fonds complémentaires pour
donner de l'emploi pour créer
d'investissement j'ai l'intention
d'investir ali that une partie de mes
installations entreprises
suire il faut faire attention l'argent
public doit être bien utilisé par une
agente public fait partie ni
l'hybridation des financements et c'est
très complexe que ce soit pour des
investissements publics ou des
investissements privés
moi je pense que pour nevers ce qu'il
faut c'est très concret moi si je suis
maire je crée une cité des entrepreneurs
il ya un site ici près de bien c'est le
site en phase de vie that ainsi des
entrepreneurs qui permettrait d'avoir
une migration progressive de jeunes
pousses entreprises qui travaillerait
sur la mutualisation de moyens de
ressources et qui une fois établies
pourraient trouver leur nid par exemple
des zones de nevers saint-eloi qui
méritent des porteurs de projet s'est
également mise en place d'un site
internet sur un modèle que j'ai
découvert en auvergne auvergne odile
s'est concrètement accompagner les
familles qui arrivent à nevers je suis
arrivé en 2008 j'ai vécu un porteur de
projet il vient avec une femme et des
enfants souvent où il vient avec un
projet et une envie il faut
l'accompagner matériellement il faut
l'accompagner au niveau de son projet il
faut aussi faire vendre nos verts qu'ils
aiment venir
aujourd'hui le problème c'est
l'attractivité de la ville également
instaurer plus d'efficacité entre les
différents services
il ya une ville il ya une agglomération
il ya un département il ya une région il
ya des services économiques qui se met
l'inde au dessus de l'autre permettre
l'expression je pense qu'il est grand
temps de mutualiser tous ces services
économiques dans un seul but
qui est de ramener de l'emploi dans la
nièvre mais surtout à 9 heures j'insiste
sur ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure le
plus grand mal de nevers c'est son socle
démographique
parce qu on ne réduira pas la fiscalité
on n'arrivera pas à redonner une
dynamique à nevers si on ne travaille
pas sur un point clé ramener des
habitants solvable avec un pouvoir
d'achat porteurs de projets à nevers ce
doit être le combat de tous les jours
d'un maire du viie siècle et messieurs
bédié pardon je vous coupe parce que
vous êtes bien certain de gens qui sont
en retard dans le temps de parole c'est
philippe cordier et c'est surtout
florent sainte fare garnot qui est celui
de fou qui est pour l'instant parler le
moins une réponse les cordier tout de
même sur les emplois et florent sainte
fare garnot vous donnera une forte houle
sur le développement économique
je pense que si ces élections
municipales sont si des élections
communautaire et je pense que le
développement économique c'est l'adn
comment voulez vous que des
investisseurs et des entrepreneurs
viennent dans la nièvre
quand on sait déjà que la cotisation
foncière des entreprises la fameuse ces
feux qui a remplacé la taxe
professionnelle a été mis par monsieur
didier boulaud déjà au taquet cder vous
avez 20 % de cette taxe c'est un frein
tout ça sent bon
en plus le vert ne ne dispose pas de
réserves foncières très importante pour
installer des entreprises bon on à la
caserne pittié ou d'un seul coup on
vient de découvrir que on pourrait
éventuellement faire des espaces verts
ou faire des terrains abattre le mur
plein de taxes que ce que l'on réclame
depuis que ce temps bon si on vient de
découvrir et là on aura une réserve
foncière je pense de de qualité déjà
rebonds mais ce que je veux ce que je
veux bien dire c'est que le
développement économique cédaient plus
avides de nevers c'est l'adn et on a d
une pression fiscale trop important qui
qui ne nécessite pas une installation
des entrepreneurs et des entreprises
ça c'est un premier plan points deuxième
point je vois que monsieur le maire
toujours donne toujours par exemple au
niveau de la ville de nevers du stade de
rugby dont je pense qu'on entend par
ailleurs il s'agirait de vue du musée de
la faïence du multiplexe le multiplex il
faut bien savoir que c'est une
entreprise privée qu'il la montée la
ville n'a fait qu'à ranger la rue de
charleville
il n'y a pas eu d'autres investissements
au niveau de la ville le musée de la
faïence ça fait dix ans qu'on en parle
où on vient enfin de l'ouvrir pour miser
pour me rendre à être plusieurs fois
dans ce musée
je constate que le taux de fréquentation
de ce musée n'est quand même pas
extraordinaire alors bien sûr on nous
donne des chiffres et donnant ces
chiffres on inclut en fait les dix jours
qui ont été de gratuité c'est dire où il
ya eu un un afflux de personnes
bon je crois que là il faut vraiment que
replacer des gens
le contexte en disant que nous sommes au
taquet au niveau de la cfe et que nous
n'arriverons pas à attirer des
entrepreneurs tant que cette cfe ne sera
pas baisser la garde
c'est ce qu'est ce que ça serait un
levier est ce que ça ce sera un moteur
c'est une proposition
alors concrètement sur la question
économique d'abord c'est la question qui
me passionne le mur je suis un homme de
gauche c'est connu je suis attaché au
service public de la ville je crois
qu'ils ont une certaine qualité reconnue
en général et ce pour quoi je me bats
depuis trois ans que je suis maire c'est
vraiment de relancer une dynamique de la
ville c'est plus important je crois que
c'est déjà le cas je dis sincèrement sur
les projets municipaux on va pas les re
cité mais tout ce qui est blanc des
grands équipements qui embellissent la
ville et qu'ils rendent des services
s'est déjà lancée il s'agit d'aller plus
loin sur l'économie c'est vrai l'outil
principal c'est l'agglomération de
nevers et donc le maire de nevers que je
suis sera candidat demain si je suis
réélu à la présidence de l'agglomération
et l'enjeu c'est de faire de
l'agglomération le fer de lance du
développement économique et c'est
vraiment une nouvelle étape qu'il s'agit
de construire quelque chose qui n'existe
pas encore qui a été construit puisque
nous avons depuis un an
bâti un nouveau projet d'agglomération
avec tous les élus et tous les maires
qui nous entoure
l'idée c'est quoi c'est pas une question
fiscale avant qui est posée c'est plutôt
innovation je le disais tout sert
innovation soutien à nos filières
l'automobile peut être soutenue à
travers les âges
on en a parlé la filière bois vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure la possibilité
d'avoir un lieu pour accueillir
des jeunes pousses qui grandissent alors
j'ai une bonne nouvelle je n'en veux pas
si vous connaissez pas encore très bien
les dossiers
ça existe déjà c'est le projet innover
on s'est lancés on s'est financée par
l'agglomération et c'est effectivement
en face 10 à 2 lits that he l'idée c'est
quoi c'est au fond nous disposons
d'atouts
nous disposons de levier avec
l'agglomération et surtout les
financements européens désormais sont
tournés vers l'entreprise et tournée
vers l'emploi
mais l'idée c'est que nos verres avec un
maire dynamique puisse proposer une
impulsion vers les entreprises
créatrices d'emplois c'est ça tout
bêtement tout simplement mais c'est dur
au quotidien quand on est maire en juge
la solidité du monde sa difficulté c'est
ça que je veux faire alors je vous
propose d'avancer je vous ai tous envie
de répondre médecine on va très spéciaux
mais ils me rendent ce bon une seconde
pour pour dire vous ne reviendrez pas
dans la partie suivante je n'ai
absolument pas là mais je préfère
intervenir ici parce que moi j'ai envie
de croire le maire de nevers j'ai envie
de le croire
et puis quand il s'exprime en disant
qu'on connaît pas les dossiers c'est
dommage parce que quand on prépare une
campagne on travaille on on suit des
dossiers moi j'ai envie de lui poser une
seule question esquissé par exemple les
gens qui figure sur sa liste se targue
d'être président de telle ou telle
structure associative et c est ce qu il
connaît par exemple l'association sos
racisme à laquelle il octroie un
logement pour faire ces réunions et c
est ce qui connaît ce dossier par
exemple je ne veux pas être cruel envers
vous mais quand on a un engagement au
front national et convient de versoix et
ce racisme je voudrais juste une réponse
et vous répond c'est un sujet sur
lesquels on évite de pointer le doigt
c'est vrai je crois que vos nouveaux
amis ne comprennent pas très bien votre
parcours ni sa cohérence politique ut
yade et il ya des héritages qui sont
dures à porter mais par contre pour
concernant sosracisme savez on a fait
juste une petite recherche excuses
exceptionnelles
la municipalité met à disposition un
regard de loi tout comprendre ou lancer
dans des duels
c'est simplement pour parler d'économie
vous savez les subventions qui sont
distribués à des associations fantômes
comme sos racisme l'association qui
s'est pas réuni depuis 2007 et on va en
2012 que la mairie met un appartement à
disposition de cette structure c'est
quand même inacceptable
on ne connaît pas les dossiers à la
municipale jour de l'air qu'on avance
sur des faits concrets on s'était promis
de parler d'un ensemble de faits
concrets c'est lé moment face mais vous
allez on va parler les garderies arriver
ses meurtriers à la personne n'en a
parlé
mais le désenclavement de nevers mais on
n'y étant pas d'économie à eybens on y
vient dans les faits concrets râler je
fais des bons aussi ces gens n'ont que
stéphane vergeade notre partenaire du
journal du centre viennent nous
rejoindre
il attend patiemment sur le bord du
décor bonjour de badges bonjour les
lions bonjour à tous journalistes
journal du centre spécialistes de la vie
locale
alors allez parcours on commence alors
on voit bien jusqu'à présent au cours
cette première demi heure les lignes de
fracture qui sont les vôtres ça c'est ça
semble très clair et vos différences
d'appréciation fiscale démographique
je vous propose maintenant on entre
vraiment dans un dossier qui plus que
tout autre
ces dernières semaines agite la campagne
et vous divise c'est celui de centre
aquatique de la jonction évoqué par
monsieur le maire il ya quelques
semaines des images de synthèse
architecturalement innovantes on parle
d'un dossier 17 millions d'euros pour
remettre le contexte n'était à 24
auparavant une participation annoncée de
l'agglo il n'empêche que vous tous les
concurrents de monsieur le maire vous
dit oulala projet pharaonique nevers
vaut bien trop grand vous monsieur le
maire n'est ce pas aux politiques un peu
risqué à l'approché des municipales
et vous que proposez vous messieurs les
candidats on commence par florent sainte
fare garnot juste pour ceux qui nous
regardent qui ne sont pas de mauvais ran
ouvert il ya un projet d'un centre
nautique extrêmement important sachant
que la ville était par rapport à
d'autres villes relativement
sous-équipés on va dire sur ce sujet là
florent sainte fare garnot qui tout le
monde alors il ya un besoin on va
commencer par cette évidence puisque la
piscine des bords de loire et vieille
elle va bientôt malheureusement devoir
être fermé
ensuite le projet que nous présentons
c'est un projet qui est simple c'est une
piscine simple et populaire écologique
parce qu'elle sera un peu consommatrices
d'énergie et c'est important pour moi et
pour la liste qui m'entourent et c'est
une piscine sur un site exceptionnel
avec lequel il ya un lien affectif
profond puisque beaucoup beaucoup de nos
versoix ont appris à nager sur la
piscine de la jonction historique donc
l'idée c'est tout simplement de
retrouver ce cycle le lieu sera
exceptionnel avec une vue sur le fleuve
sur le port de la jonction avec une vue
sur la ville et sur la cathédrale et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que nous avions une
estimation initiale à 24 millions parce
que c'est un projet qui est raisonnable
et pas du tout comme d'aucuns peuvent le
dire
excessif par ailleurs parce que nous
avons bien négocié nous sommes
redescendus de 24 à 17 millions et nous
allons soumettre le 28 février au
conseil d'agglomération une délibération
qui fera que celui ci participera à
hauteur de 7,5 millions d'euros pour ce
projet donc au fond très beau projet
projet de coeur un j'en parle avec
passion parce que je me suis investi
beaucoup et projet qui ne coûtera pas un
centime de plus aux nos verts soient
fiscalement c'est très important
oui je pense qu'on rêve mais je pense
qu'un horaire on a besoin de réalité
pour qu'on puisse réellement avancer ce
qui n'est pas le cas
mon rêve parce que d'une part ce projet
on devrait pas l'évoquer dans cette
période électorale on devrait déjà
pouvoir se baigner mettre ses orteils
dans une piscine à deux verres c'est pas
le cas donc c'est devenu un enjeu
électoral donc à bord dont le rêve parce
qu'on veut faire un partenariat public
privé qui peut parfois présenter des
avantages et qui vient souvent est un
marché de dupes avec une entreprise qui
est là pour réaliser des bénéfices si on
le comprend avec une collectivité qui
n'est pas forcément capable de financer
ce projet et quand on vous dit on l'a
ramené à 17 millions d'euros
les services de la ville était au
conseil régional il ya quelques jours
pour négocier une une base d' enveloppe
sur 24 millions d'euros et nous sommes
bien 24 millions d'euros et dans le
cadre d'un financement public privé
ça va coûter à peu près 50 millions
d'euros ono versoix donc c'est un projet
qui est d'abord assez paradoxal parce
que c'est quand même la municipalité
actuelle qui a fermé la jonction très
brutalement en mettant le parc salengro
payant les deux choses ont été très mal
vécue par les no versoix et moi
effectivement je tiens également à cette
piscine de la jonction pour avoir
rencontré les riverains qui n'ont pas vu
des lui depuis des années qu'ils n'ont
pas franchi le pont eux sont très
réservés d'abord parce que il ya des
démolitions de leurs habitations qui
n'ont pas été dit il ya des travaux de
voirie qui vont augmenter la charge de
ce coup c'est important c'est la réalité
les choses il ya moins de circulation
sur le pont noir pour une piscine
ouverte à l'année
et puis est ce qu'on a besoin d'une
piscine de cette taille parce qu'on vous
dit c'est une piscine raisonnable c'est
un centre aquatique avec un coût
d'entrée qui va être élevé et qui va
forcément limiter la fréquentation de
cet endroit où elle avait ramené nous
avons une réflexion de dire on prend le
temps oppose les choses et on en fait un
projet d'agglomération pas une
subvention d'agglomération qu'on nous
annonce à 7 millions et demi qui n'est
pas votée qui n'est pas voter puisque le
vote interviendra le 28 février
on n'en sait rien à ce jour il ya un
engagement principe c'est tout je pense
qu'il faut revenir à quelque chose de
raisonnable accessibles également
milieux sportifs qu'on a longtemps
oublié regarder l'état du stade de la
baratte et de la piste d'athlétisme on a
reçu les championnats de france et c'est
le révélateur d'après mme d'anticipation
pourquoi nous avions cette piscine des
bords de loire nous connaissons la durée
de vie d'une piscine nous avions cette
piscine de la jonction de connexion sont
d'état et on n'a rien fait avant et on a
laissé pourrir les choses et aujourd'hui
on se trouve confronté à deux voire à
larache pardonnez moi l'expression se
prononcer et engager les neuf et reçoit
pour très longtemps
je suis pas sûr que monsieur le maire
restera forcément très longtemps dans la
nef s'il échoue mais pour nous c'est un
projet qui effectivement excessif mais
juste un morceau déjà c'est pas un
partenariat public rue et c'est une
délégation de service public par voie
qu'on sait si mais bon faudrait aussi
les dossiers mais quand vous aurez
intégrer les dents mais quand vous
l'avez réalisme en suisse que vous quand
vous aurez intégrer la liste que
monsieur garneau aux vautours vous
pourrez avoir lui aussi un mot là-dessus
parce que je vois rien de dire ça c'est
quand même lui qui a siégé avec l'équipe
municipale et c'est quand même lui il ya
six ans qui a ramené les voix notamment
dans certains quartiers à la mairie je
suis personne vole pas je sais je sais
je n'attends rien son père et sur lequel
vous avez de la suite dans les idées
vous l'avez dit vous arriverez de masse
parce qu'ils veulent pas vous donner de
place alors vous retrouverez à faire une
liste a été trompée vous parce que si
vous êtes attentifs à la chronologie
j'ai posé mon mouvement à mon engagement
bien avant que la liste du parti
socialiste soit débattue et oui parce
que vous saviez déjà bien d'indépendants
alors comme ça s'est fait un petit signe
comme alors juste je reprends un voulait
réguler voire un sur ce gâteau la
nouvelle ambition projet monsieur
monsieur boulot à l'époque alors en fait
lui déjà s'il fallait dire sur une
piscine et là on recommence on va finir
par se noyer à nevers alors sachant que
c'est une piscine qui souhaitent être
construit dans une zone inondable et
puis j'attire attention vous avez
réfléchi sur you la liste de tout le
monde tout l'équipement lourd mais
surtout il n'y a aucun chantier public
qui se déroule sans dérapages et vous on
a quand même des précédents en france
sur les dix dernières années qu'ils sont
extraordinaires
prenez par exemple la philharmonie là le
bourg de la musique 175 millions d'euros
budgétés
on termine à plus de 400 millions que
vous êtes en train de nous dire c'est
que la ville de nevers ne peut pas se
payer un projet qui serait au delà d'un
service national mensonge cette histoire
de piscines où nous sommes confrontés
comme mille autres communes au
vieillissement de notre investissement
notre infrastructure aquatique c'est un
proche de projets rappelez-vous d'emile
piscine des années suivantes 10 donc à
l'opposition air qui arrivent des
complètement désarmé à chaque fois à la
maison des secrets et des géants coréens
s'exonère espérions tous les goûts oui
mais tout à fait on est indépendant on
est indépendant et à l'intégrisme ne
suffit pas de tirer sur tout le monde et
donc quand leur position arrive au
conseil municipal complètement désarmé
c'est extraordinaire il suffit de se
renseigner un petit peu et voyez qu'il
ya des rénovations qui sont possibles
prenez l'exemple de la ville de creil
pour 7 millions d'euros on a un mal j'ai
cousu bains bouillonnants on a une
piscine magnifique si on la fait un
cadre d'un kwassa s'est proposé ce
week-end
on en reparlera tout à l'heure c'est une
ville de 35 mille habitants comme nevers
qui s'est doté d'un investissement
structurant de qualité et moi je vous
fais même le pari si on le fait en
délégation de service public ça coûtera
pas un euro vers soi et on peut faire la
même chose pour la piscine de la
jonction
puisque il suffit de faire le devis nous
l'avons demandé moins d'un million
d'euros pour rénover la piscine de la
jonction
soit trois années de la piscine jetables
verts de loire voilà la réalité
et voilà ce que nous voulons faire votre
cote est à vous je veux réagir c'est
effectivement un sujet qui vend la
piscine de la jonction
déjà je trouve assez assez cynique ce
sens nous regardons vous parlez de
d'affect d'innover reçoit pour le signe
de la jonction me semble que c'est vous
même avec votre municipalité qu'il avait
fermé cette piscine
c'est un grand choc quand je venais
d'arriver dans la nièvre j'ai eu la
chance d'y être une année et après
terminé quand on voit l'état de la
piscine depuis six ans ça fait peur vous
dites que les ne verse courant voisin
d'une piscine certes
par contre on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'agglomération je trouve qu'il ya un
manque de cohérence d'agglomération il
existe des centres aquatiques au sein
d'agglomérations à varennes-vauzelles il
ya un centre aquatique un fils il ya
c'est un centre aquatique un finissant
dans l'agglomération millien centre
aquatique
il ya déjà une offre aquatique qui
existe sur monsieur sur sur
l'agglomération de nevers
il ya la piscine des bords de loire elle
fait partie effectivement du projet
d'emile piscine moi j'ai travaillé
différemment si j'ai la chance d'être
élu maire dans quelques semaines
j'espère pouvoir tout mettre en oeuvre
pour casser ce que vous mettez sur la
table en ce moment faire des votes au 28
février quand on n'a jamais été élu
maire de nevers engagé la collectivité
sur des projets aussi ambitieux je
rappelle quand même opus et 17 18
millions d'euros c'est énorme par
rapport à la vocation de l'ovaire moi
j'ai une vision des choses c'est rénover
la piscine de la jonction comme elle
l'était nous parler d'un million d'euros
moi j'ai plutôt sur 2 millions d'euros
en faire une piscine d'été comme l a été
pour nevers pendant des années rendra à
ce côté de la loire ce côté un petit peu
stival et capitaliser sur l'existant si
je suis élu maire j'ai un projet de
travailler sur la piscine des bords de
loire
c'est disney bord de loire est
vieillissant par contre elle n'est pas
pour moi
vieillissante au point de fermer j'ai
comme intention d'ouvrir une patinoire
une patinoire artistique patinoire
sportives qui se rate une patinoire qui
sera greffée la piscine qui offrira une
nouvelle offre d'agglomération qui n'ira
pas à l'encontre des offres privées qui
sera raisonnable qui sera basée sur un
partenariat public privé qui sera dans
le quartier des courlis d'un quartier
des bords de loire à quartiers
populaires avec un parking à côté avec
géant casino pour ne pas le citer
ça permettra de redonner une nouvelle
vie d'offrir une nouvelle offre sportive
et culturelle ou non vers soi pour un
coût tout à fait raisonnable je vous
coupe le meilleur pour que parce que
vous êtes en fait je veux terminer je
veux terminer windows large en terme de
temps de parole je prend le large 1
rénover la piscine d'hellemmes sur la
joue sion comme elle l'était de mettre
une piscine rénovée avec une patinoire
permanente contre-projet qu'on a compris
contre projet le bilan global 5 millions
d'euros monsieur quand prof en moi que
le maire actuel et je confierai
l'exploitation de cette patinoire un
organisme privé ça ne coûtera pas un
euro de plus owni versoix monsieur
cordier ou là vous de vous exprimer ses
sincères dossier sur lequel vous avez
été particulièrement offensif et encore
lundi soir au conseil municipal vous
avez justement agité la thèse des
expropriations alors ignorant sainte
fare garnot il dit c'est pas vrai
mais bon j'espère que c'est le maire
tiendra sa parole et il a sûrement des
documents qui nous prouverons que il est
là tout à fait il respectera tout à fait
sa part moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que notre l'opposition en fait de
nevers a depuis la fermeture de la
piscine des bords de loire exprimé son
opposition à cette piscine faisant
quelques manifestations à l'époque qui
qui disait tout simplement non nous
pouvons rénové effectivement cette
piscine de bord de loire et de la
jonction je veux dire et parce qu'en
fait elle n'a jamais été entretenue quoi
le problème de nevers idée là pourquoi
le petit théâtre est fermée parce qu'il
n'a jamais entretenu pourquoi la piscine
de la jonction est fermée parce qu'elle
n'a jamais été entretenue que les
équipements effectivement deviennent
vétuste et dangereux notamment pour la
sécurité
nous ce que nous voulons alors content
pour répondre à monsieur georges on
connaît quand même un petit peu le
dossier donc nous sommes allés dans
quelques vides qui ont en effet scellé
sera en tout cas là des centres des
centres nautiques et nous sommes allés
particulièrement évolution de 39 milles
habitants ont dû sont ils ont fait une
piscine qui s'appelle le site de la loue
et je crois et qui cette piscine à un
grand bassin petit bassin d fosse de
plongée des restaurants enfin un
restaurant et un centre ludique
coût de l'opération alors il y a trois
ans 9 millions d'euros
moi ce qui m'inquiète dans ce projet de
piscine c'est que c'est cette piscine va
être construite si vous voulez sur un
terrain inondable qu'elle sera donc sur
pilotis et que en fait le coût de
construction annoncés par
c st- fare garnot de 17 millions me
paraît tout à fait en dessous de la
réalité
et j'aurais j'aurais tendance à croire
que ce coût ne pourra être qu augmenter
et
participera pas ce que la piscine de la
jonction d'accord mais il ya aussi des
charges de gestion qui sont à la à la
charge qui seront à la charge de la
mairie de nevers et l'adn pour l'instant
ne prend pas la compétence on ne sait
pas si le 28 février
l'adn acceptera de prendre la compétence
au niveau de la piscine donc en fait
c'est un petit peu un écran de fumée je
pense que c'est le le projet du maire
chaque mère à son à son projet on a eu
le petit tas de pierre bérégovoy on a
maintenant la piscine de la jonction
je pense que chacun a son projet je
pense que c'est pas le bon projet en
fait de nevers quand vous rencontrez des
gens là ne vers la première question
qu'ils ne posent c'est pas et de son
trac wathiq alors c'est ouvre quand ça
va être fait quand non les gens ils ont
d'autres préoccupations dans le verizon
des provocations de taxes enfin on va
pas revenir là dessus mais de taxe
d'habitation d'apollo qu'autre chose
comme ça qu'on avait essayé d'en parler
déjà christophe dire oui moi quand on
évoque des montants de 24 17 millions 50
millions etc je pense tout de suite aux
tropiques this nombril et les projets le
projet en l'espèce france tout de suite
et immédiatement aux petits chefs
d'entreprise aux personnes qui perdent
leur emploi etc et qui sont face à des
dossiers comme ça alors je sais bien que
ça peut paraître pour nous une
discussion politique politicienne je
vois simplement que le bon évidemment
messieurs sainte fare garnot qui est
tombé amoureux de nevers qui nous vient
de de versailles se prend pour le petit
roi soleil ici veut des projets
pharaoniques
bon il fait un peu office de marchand de
sable en nous vendant des projets qui
sont sur la table depuis 2008 quoi pour
les dernières municipales on nous avait
déjà fait le coup une étude à environ 1
million d'euros d'ailleurs sur le site
de l'ancien hôpital
aujourd'hui on remet on remet encore une
louche supplémentaires sur un projet
d'une piscine qui a été fait en 58
moi aussi je vais prendre l'exemple de
creil moi aussi je veux le prendre cet
exemple parce que créa il existe il a
été inauguré l'année dernière c'est une
c'est une piscine non non non mais je
rêve c'est vrai parce que je connais
bien créons ces points de ville de votre
bord dont je connais bien cry d'ailleurs
c'est une ville socialiste
avec un maire qui a des difficultés lui
aussi avec hbo bon nombre de liste
contre lui parce que et malgré cela
malgré cela creil a construit 35000
habitants créer une piscine aléas en
gros 10 millions 10 millions avec des
bassins en inox tous les accès
handicapés trois niveaux sauna hammam et
c est là aujourd'hui on vous propose 600
mètres carrés
vous allez rire ne fait pas pour ça non
mais c'est pas marrant parce que
aujourd'hui on se demande ce que va nous
proposer le maire alors aujourd'hui il
nous annoncer un projet à 24 millions
deux articles de presse plus tard on
tombe à 17 bon apparemment c'est vrai
qu'il n'a pas fait d'école de commerce
plutôt une école de science-fiction
sciences politiques pardon mais je le
crois que c'est pouvoir de négociation
sont quand même assez faible
donc monsieur le maire trop faire de
science fiction pour faire un peu de
l'audience mobile de la science
politique je dois d'abord il faut avoir
le sourire dans tout ça ce qu'on entend
beaucoup de choses
la première chose c'est le plus
important c'est de retrouver un site
exceptionnel avec lequel les navires
soient en lien affectif c'est
l'essentiel
et c'est aussi un dossier qui va porter
image de la ville vers l'extérieur parce
qu'on va pouvoir dans cette piscine voir
je le disais à la fois la loire la ville
et le port de la jonction autrement dit
c'est un effet carte postale que nous
allons proposer à ceux qui vont venir le
visiter
donc l'enjeu pour nous c'est quoi c'est
de faire aimer nevers de la faire
connaître notre ville et de la faire
rayonner alors sur les coûts bon j'ai
entendu beaucoup de choses à 5 millions
d'euros on peut faire une pataugeoire
peut-être certaines n'ont pas une
patinoire démago dans sa circulaire
mentionne même pas laisser passer ça sur
le fond et a sur le fond si nous avions
travaillé
avec un assistant maîtrise d'ouvragé le
dossier a été mené de manière
extrêmement solide ces deux ans de
travail avec des gens qui accompagnent
l'équipe municipale bien sûr les
chiffres ne sort pas du chapeau donc la
première des choses c'est que le nombre
de mètres carrés d'eau qui sont prévus
dans notre projet secourisme en est
exactement à ce qui existe déjà dans la
piscine des bords de loire
donc quand je dis que c'est un projet
raisonnable c'est vrai si les impétrants
veulent faire moins en termes de piscine
que la piscine des bords de loire
bien qu'ils le disent mais c'est c'est
au fond donc cela revient à cela alors
si on regarde à l'horizon vraiment le
projet je disais maîtrisé sur le plan du
coup et c'est contractuel donc
effectivement le travail incluant une
entreprise dans le cadre d'un contrat de
délégation de service public et le coût
de 17 millions
c'est un coup sur lequel l'entreprise
s'engage et donc il n'y a aucun risque
de dérapage puisque c'est
contractuellement prévu et il ya même si
jamais les calendriers n'était pas
respecté un certain nombre de pénalités
qui sont prévus pour garantir une
avancée dynamique du projet un mot sur
l'expropriation on a entendu ce mois ci
c'est très important parce que je sais
que il peut y avoir des interrogations
et je pense notamment aux riverains de
la future piscine
je me suis rendu chez une dame de 82 ans
on a bu un thé et figurez-vous elle m'a
dit tout ce qu'elle avait à me dire et
ses craintes et je me suis engagé à ce
qu' il n'y ait aucune expropriation et
je suis en mesure de le confirmer
puisque le projet a évolué dans
l'utilisation des parcelles qui sont
prévues et les parkings étaient
initialement prévus un endroit qui
supposait effectivement qu'il y est
des expropriations et nous avons fait
évoluer le projet le parking sera
ailleurs et il n'y aura aucune
expropriation
alors je vous propose de me rappeler que
nous sommes en zone inondable avec un
surcoût de 3 millions d'euros rien que
pour ce motif
je vous propose d'avancer un tout petit
peu on va pas pouvoir parler du tgv on
n'a plus le temps il nous reste trois il
nous reste trois minutes avant la pause
de midi
il faut qu'on fasse un peu de politique
vous l'avez amorcé tout à l'heure je
suis désolé mais pour que les gens qui
nous regardent comprennent bien falloir
vous nous parler un petit peu de vous
les uns et les autres avant conclut et
on va commencer par ceux qui sont un
petit peu en retard le temps de parole
mais denis thuriau on a vu une question
sur internet quelqu'un demandait mais
denis thuriau appartient-il toujours au
parti socialiste pourquoi est il
candidat c'est peut-être l'occasion de
nous expliquer et puis se récrie rui de
sûr je pense que j'ai été clair dès le
début je ne fais plus partie du parti
socialiste depuis fin 2012
je suis quelqu'un de conviction j'ai eu
des engagements j'ai des valeurs
je suis avant tout quelqu'un libre et
l'indépendant je fais une profession
d'avocat qui est aussi libre et
indépendante et je partirai je me
retrouve plus un endroit je n'en fais
plus partie contrairement à ce que peut
penser monsieur est hors jeu qui lui
appartient un parti qui fait partie de
l'actuel gouvernement alors moi je
souhaite simplement à recentrer les
choses localement
parce que j'ai souhaité constituer est
proposée au no versoix et une anversoise
une liste requis soient ouvertes qui
réunissent des sensibilités diverses une
liste républicaine et puis surtout qui
associe les beaux compétences de notre
credo ce sont les bonnes personnes aux
bonnes places et pas simplement faire de
la distribution ou plaisir à certaines
personnes je pense que associer les
compétences dès le départ c'est une
preuve d'efficacité et c'est
effectivement un mouvement qui se veut
réellement sincère pour nevers pas de
parti un parti pris notre ville et son
agglomération
alors on évoquera après la pause de midi
aussi la situation à droite puisque vous
êtes deux candidats de partis qu'on
pourrait considérer comme proches
il nous reste une minute trente
j'aimerais juste christophe gaillard que
vous nous parliez un petit peu de vous
et puis je vous ai fait part de mon
étonnement tout à l'heure parce
qu'effectivement vous êtes candidat pour
le front national votre parcours a déjà
été ok vous venez de
gauche vous n'avez jamais évoquer les
thèmes du front national par exemple
quand vous parliez d'emploi de
préférence nationale
vous avez parlé de subventions
européennes alors qu'on sait que le
parti de marine le pen est largement
anti européen expliquez nous comment
vous positionner c'est tout simple en
fait je crois que je suis pas le seul à
défendre cette ligne à au front national
florian philippot le fait également
parle d'entrepreneuriat social ce sont
des dispositifs si vous voulez qu'ils
existent au niveau européen dont il faut
saisir c'est tout il ya des fonds joue
les répéter tout à l'heure je voulais
dit on a perdu 65 millions quand même
faute de projet sur les voies
repositionnement moi j'ai un
positionnement qui est très très simple
tout le monde connaît les thèmes
centraux les enjeux les grands enjeux
défendue par le front national
simplement moi j'apporte une un côté un
peu différent un peu complémentaire
je respecte bien entendu la ligne qui me
convient le mieux
les lignes politiques du front national
donc mais au sein du rassemblement bleu
marine nous avons aussi des sensibilités
diverses qui s'exprime et moi je tiens à
faire part de mes engagements passés et
présents pour l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est important merci de ces
explications on n'a pas le temps de se
relancer sur un autre sujet puisqu'il
nous reste mieux aller une trentaine de
secondes avant les informations midi
stéphane avait prévu plein de sujets
mais une fourrure apolitique il
comparera politique mais vous avez pris
le temps aussi de traiter au fond un
sujet qui manifestement quand même pose
question à nevers sur la piscine donc
donc c'est bien aussi
merci pour cette première partie de
débat on va se retrouver juste après
d'abord la météo puis le flash
d'information midi et puis pour la
deuxième partie on continuera par les
politiques parce qu'il ya encore des
choses à dire et puis on vous permettra
à tous de
conclure cette émission